welcome to the global roundtable this
series focuses on the future of economic
competition I'm Parag Khanna joined by a
distinguished panel including dumby
samoy Oh Daniel Altman and uh none
geared Harless today we're talking about
the end of the dollar but is it the
dollar is still obviously the dominant
reserve currency but it does face
competition clearly we see that the yen
the Euro the R&B and others are getting
ever more play in global currency
exchanges so what is the future of the
global monetary system going to look
like some people would argue it might
not even be a relevant point but I think
if you look at the what's going on right
now is particular with the Chinese
renminbi fascinating they are lending to
organizations like the IMF and two other
economies in their currency they're
doing swap agreements trade agreements
based on the renminbi longer term the
concern is about whether there's
actually financial infrastructure
developed enough in China to sustain a
role as a global reserve currency but
the fact of the matter is that they are
the big lender around the world not just
to the west across Africa Latin America
Europe and Australia and so the facts of
the matter is that they will be playing
a bigger role and their current will be
greater demand look with reserves you
can have as many currencies in the
basket as you want people thought the
euro was going to be the great
alternative to the dollar now there are
a lot of questions about the euro if you
look at the euro countries long-term
potential to grow in their risks they
could be heading in four different
directions but you do need one currency
for things like trading oil that's where
the IMF the International Monetary Fund
wants to step in and offer their own
currency which is a mix of other
currencies but who decides what the mix
is maybe it's just the IMF trying to
reassert its relevance nobody denies the
West is going to lose a certain amount
of power relative power the big question
that remains is even as it loses that
power can it at least maintain certain
kind of mediating roles like being
really runs currency of the world being
the military that goes into kind of
police situations even those things are
now starting to fall away Daniel just
because there should be a standard
global currency doesn't mean has to be
one of the existing ones what about the
idea of the IMF Special Drawing rights
strs that's a problematic idea because
the sdrs are really built as
combinations of other currencies there
has to be an exchange rate between the
sdrs and other currencies so you have to
know how much they're worth in dollars
eros etc but who decides how much of a
dollar how much of a euro
etc goes into that basket that forms the
SDR that's an extremely powerful
decision to be able to make and I think
the IMF a wants to be able to make it
because they are feeling a little bit
irrelevant these days and be it's it's a
decision where the IMF's board is going
to have a lot of say and countries like
China and Korea growing economies or
having more and more of a say on that
board what about the fact that not only
can you transition away towards a basket
of some kind but countries have the
right to define the basket as they so
choose in terms of differing
compositions for example you're counting
out Europe but they're still many
countries buying the euro and in fact
the eurozone will actually expand
despite everything that's happened
because some of the smaller countries
whether it's Iceland or in Eastern
Europe Balkan countries they actually
still want to join the euro zone so we
are going to have a multipolar
multi-currency world whether we like it
or not and it's not necessarily going to
be harmonized standardized or led by the
IMF or anyone else so is there a way out
of that sort of chaos currency chaos i
would say that we don't need a way out
as long as our computers can keep all
the numbers straight but it does make it
a little more difficult for us as
consumers and investors to see what
we're getting at any time it means that
not only are we going to have to
internationalize our portfolios we're
going to have to think a lot more about
currency risk when we plan for the
future and I would just add to that by
saying countries are already voting with
their feet I mean the the Chinese
government as an example has a portfolio
and it's deciding right now whether it
wants to put it in Euros where they
wants to hold in dollars and we know
what the impact on the market of those
type of decisions are so I think you
very much see that sort of nation
determination which is about currency
baskets which is done from as a national
level that story as it as it evolved is
going to have a major impact of course
on global economic competition thanks
very much for your insights more on that
and many other relevant topics at big
thing calm
you